he is a wide receiver for the Pittsburgh
Steelers he was on Dancing with the
Stars and even half of my friends who
didn't know who Antonia was because they
don't watch sports now are obsessed with
him because he is a very good-looking
man Antonio are you on the line
fantastic how are you yeah what are you
doing right now you got an update yes
all day I'm out here on the trail
relaxing before I go to Pittsburgh just
about to get a little workout in before
I head home for a couple hours you
always have my favorite was talking to
you about Dancing with the Stars and you
would always say business is what Boman
business is boomin so what does Antonio
Brown do on his off day well today I'm
gonna get a little workout in so just a
light cardio and some plyo movements I
need a credit card because it's like two
weeks and from Kemp I've been running on
my feet all day so I need to get the
cows to shake now do you get the callus
remover do you pay the extra five
dollars to get the callus remover you
have to you have to write which one
which one of your teammates needs a
pedicure are you gonna take Ben with you
oh I don't know Ben lose it I mean he's
doing a lot but probably probably
already burns the quarterback he's been
trying to cover me Chinese direction I'm
sure you can use his feet to be a little
bit lighter oh hey okay
some shade you know I don't know if
you've seen this Antonio first of all
thank you for calling in we're all happy
to be talking to you the big year for
the Steelers a lot of expectations for
you and we'll get into that in a second
but I don't know if you saw Brandon
Marshall had this little bet with you
did you see that where he said he would
give you his portion yeah in exchange
for your is a Rolls Royce yes if you
guys if he has more receiving yards than
than you is that what how that works out
yeah that's what he put out there yeah
do you accept the bet I mean you know
was raised enough voice is definitely a
different value
I think Brendan knows my quarterback
being Ben Roethlisberger I don't know I
know he understands what we do in the
passing game show I don't think he
really meant that that I think he just
put it out there to be funny and to get
some cool ahead lon
I'll get some cool headlines well you've
got a Porsche probably is what you're
thinking at this point then right
judging by your answer the papers we
still do papers exchanging of papers as
it's just a throwback Antonia what do
you most looking forward to about this
year of course there's no martavis
bryant with the suspension but what is
something that you're focused on for
this upcoming season well I want to get
better you know you either get better
are you like your worship you know I was
want to continue to grow and I do myself
every year and I'm decided about the
opportunities to get a chance to compete
and play with the stones again and it
has to win the world championship
I'm sure that you saw this the Hall of
Fame game was cancelled because of the
turf the NFL saying that they were
protecting players safety you think is
the right decision I think was the right
decision
totally I think we played at a game
basher and I see my kicker Shaun switch
them I see her east up on that field
mm-hmm they'll be what the smart move is
is a really hard turn and definitely not
a great surface having played on that
field how would you describe it well I
didn't actually play on advice and
teammates that played on it okay well we
played in the Hall of Fame game last
year and they said it was really hard
and I kicked it actually got hurt on
that field last year we were also
talking about the number of preseason
games I argue I mean as a fan I want to
see as much football as possible that
being said I feel like the preseason is
too long and we always talk about you
know player safety would you be if
somebody was to give you you know I
don't know Dell's job for a day
preseason or no preseason
I'm being preseason as always well you
know a good opportunity for the younger
players to get experience you know to
get a couple of NFL games on that built
for the coaches in the scouting
department that accentuate what God you
know could be getting ready and could be
a part of team so I think preseason is
definitely necessary to uh to give you
prepare for the season and get good to
players in the scouts opportunity to
evaluate practice later
you mentioned the younger guys how much
the veterans need it though that big the
veterans you know I understand over the
course of the season the routines and
what it takes and what kind of sick they
want to be in so I think for the
veterans you know is uh it's not really
needed that much my still could get your
game ready for the season speaking of
game ready you spent your offseason
participating and Dancing with the Stars
you did very well
did you surprise yourself no it was a
really surprising I thought it would be
a great challenge for me not only from
our silhouette well further my mentality
you know coming off a concussion last
year you know I wanna make sure my - the
program the shot that I could wreak on
memory and recall things quick and I
think learning dances every week was
pretty good for my not only for me
physically when I'm in those yeah
absolutely probably a lot harder
everyone always says whoever goes on the
show always has the same response it's a
lot harder than you think it would be
agree absolutely you got a dance in the
studio four hours a day you got a camera
blocking on Sunday so it's a little
college season go for about twelve weeks
from a smart six to about May all the
way up to OTA so definitely challenge
definitely was a lot to work to be put
in and definitely a lot of learning to
do of course I'm filling in for Dan
Patrick because he's at the Olympics
covering it down there of course for NBC
so Antonio if you could participate in
any Olympic sport obviously outside of
football if they had it what would it be
how shocking for track-and-field mm-hmm
what I'm saying Usain Bolt's style yeah
we gotta line it up one time yes you
saying boat in the hundred that'd be
pretty cool right who's who's the
fastest player in the league right now I
know it's a lot of fat guys you know
different sizes football fans you track
that I think it's a lot of speed out
there you can't really be in with guy
you know some guys are forties better
some guys got breakaway speed on the
field sometimes could be checkout leave
stuff you know there's uh it kind of
differentiate but it's a lot of speed
out there a lot of questions of course
surrounding getting paid not getting
paid where's your head out with all that
well other things on my mind you want to
be a great player you want to be
compensated and you want to be up there
with Italy but right now you know my
focus is totally getting in shape you
know that my agent works behind the
scenes with those teams and just
continue to grow each day I'm out there
practice and I'm performing their
pre-season just our team is not a shape
ready for the season and let my agency
work behind the scenes of course your
agent being Drew Rosenhaus he knows how
to get things done Antonio we really
really appreciate the time stay healthy
can't wait to watch out there and we'll
see you around I think you miss us
mmm ah the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience